right is there any of our comments that
members want to made right well it's a
bigger proposal for will to accept the
officers recommendation proposed by
councillor sue Ayers and it's been
seconded by Councillor Adrienne Osborne
that we accept the officers
recommendations as in our papers so with
that I'm now gonna ask rope Carmichael
to do the roll call and go through the
members to vote
Thank You chair and this is just a
confirm this on the first application
that we are looking at of I just get the
reference number for clarity 18001 so
I'll take him in order if you could
please respond with four against her
abstain so how's the suit airs for how's
the David Busbee against counselor John
Hinton against Tesla V Jameson against
Mary McLaren against cancer agent
Osbourne
against Charlie Parker against castor
Steven plum against Thank You mr. the
potion is lost
okay thank you very much
just as legal that I capture as well
indeed seven those two forces lost yes
well thank you very much
right so now I need to ask you you wish
to go forward now we need another motion
put forward by those that have voted
against Chancellor Busby thank you
well I think it's against heritage I
think the impact on heritage with
numbers policies but I think the
Heritage impact is still too great and I
think in the conclusions you mentioned
course that's ucs-2
and I'm not convinced about CS 11 being
in broad compliance either that was the
house and survey yep um yes the work
that's coming in their papers and
because we won't be staring down another
term here and I think it's really
important that we just ask articulate
previously formulate them you have
obviously there is a bridge to see up to
I think that acknowledged in your sort
of pull back following activities in the
countryside and because you remember the
thing there are no exceptional
circumstances and certainly the need for
this development isn't justifiable in
what's the harm I think just on the
broader scarce 11 econ and I was I would
be cautious about saying that there was
I think we saw that play out in the long
melt that inquiry and of you have a
vision for the sexes based on that only
a few weeks
I think it can be very difficult
certainly in the absence of any clear
direction for the country from members
on this but there isn't a need and
probably Offices of suggested that
whilst it is camp that there is a
pointing to there being a need people
don't bother development I ask counselor
to to relook at that see s if you like
the carry around the other issues
heritage okay yeah and then actually
from my on do I think this ultimately in
the heritage and I think made a number
of comments now about heritage I think
in respect of that what would be really
useful is to understand performance how
harmful it e and web addicting they're
following the offices conclusion is the
medium level of letters and to harm and
more coordinated to different potential
harm that doesn't mean as I said
previously that the harm is less
significant in MCPS parlance it just
affects the way you deal with that harm
and obviously you do attach a
considerable importance to it and I
think as a number of members who said
that the harm would would be not power
ways by the public benefit and in doing
so be also really equals one sandwich a
fish the cells are being harmed by the
or would be harmed by this building and
I think there in detail without in the
Aqsa report and indeed the previous
resolution of this committees which not
meaning to inform members of
disappointing out the matter of fact
they were brought in hall room farm by
farm and the greatest darling Thank You
councillor Busby you've heard all that
I think the cs2 Housing Survey they fear
that perhaps that wouldn't be sensible
to assume that one but you could
elaborate on the heritage medium to home
and that could carry weight with cs2
the heritage officers comments on that I
think yep he's exactly right on that I
take odds with the housing need the only
housing needs survey was conducted
before Wally Grange has been built out I
think if they conducted a housing needs
survey now which is when we're actually
doing the decision I'm not so certain
that there would be shown from residents
that would be a housing made and I think
yet the other points that I would Walter
bring this is outside the village
boundary therefore it has to show you
know a much greater positive benefit
plus there's also the harm to the SAS
well council officers I think cancel
sorry officers I think counselor Busby
has made a case for keep and see s11
Harrison survey in his recommendation
for refusal how do you want to comment
on that the we could be looking at some
as an opening for the reapers refusal
then the circumstances of the
application and the proposed development
they're not exceptional and without the
proven justifiable need concrete policy
fear fluency at 11 mmm-hmm acceptable
councillor Busby yeah it sounds good
thank you Steve and on the Fla point
saying this is something that is covered
in in the officer report and obviously
there will always be an element of harm
to the development of the green field
choice but in Landscape Services
besides not necessarily representative
at the whole of these special areas I
think relatively enclosed science and I
think we might be hard-pressed
she defended discrete and independent
landscape reason Philippines all good
again I thought that the counselor does
bian if you want to press that point
little T weaken we could keep it but I
think certainly that the heritage point
yes I mean I agree I think we're already
looking at small elements still country
and provide harm the biggest one
obviously is heritage so out of a
hundred
you should probably apply eighty points
to the Heritage there are other factors
which curative Lee add up to saying that
the harm is greater than the benefit
right thank you
I've got canceller Jemison followed by
councillor Hinton so I'll just take
counselor Jamison some
does CR come into play as to the SLA
into account Steven from policy from the
old local plan mm it is relevant purely
in respective special landscape areas
and that's why the policy tip does
require maintenance or enhancement of
the area but I I've made the point if
this is an element that the reasons for
a funeral to be put forward I think you
need to be clear you know why this would
be harmful a warrant would be contrary
about the policy and why any mitigating
measures of the violence in don't
necessarily deal with that point right
Thank You councillor Busbee do you want
to accept cro4 and if you do
you need to elaborate on it I hear what
steve says I think it's the objections
strong enough without it just makes a
point and thank you then I've got
counselor Hinton would you like to come
in now Chancellor Hinton yeah sorry just
get it to the right button the press
yes I would like to second cancel
Busby's proposal and can I suggest that
when you're looking at the final syrup
summary which is slide 44 it's in
conflict with the core strategy cs2
broad it says broad compliance on this
and I would have to say that is in broad
conflict with CS 11 and CS 15 because
not all of the points in CS 11 are
against this site but more are against
it than are in favor of it so the
balance of acceptance or harm if you
like to call it that in planning terms
is against this proposal thank you
yes okay just to say that yes we will
import them a planning balance on a
resolution checking some reasons refusal
I think they - as a neighbor to be very
clear about the reasons and
follow-through the general approach to
planning balance I'm just wondering if I
might have two minutes yeah that'll be
fine we have a couple of minute cooldown
councillor Parker's got something to say
I think oh sorry
yes councillor Parker we can take that
one who's throwing them yeah well thank
you chair I mean it just occurs to me
the reasons for refusal this time around
are precisely the same as the officer
asked if we could list the buildings
that were and so if I can help with that
I mean right Steven and I without the
proven justifiable need concrete
policies fear fear and fear eleven the
proposed development is completed to
lead to a medium level of lesson and
calm inspecting the debris field
building Broughton Hall on and on and
the complete from Babel local plan
policy fear no tip not respecting
heritage assets Toki counselor the
village or historic themes of the
Heritage campus gone through the bay the
core strategy probably fear solemnity of
the scene burn for the public benefit to
the scene chiefly the market housing
affordable housing in that don't aspire
diversity on the side are not considered
to outweigh the farm making the proposal
Contras the heritage policies at the
MPPs the development conflicts of the
development plan when taken as a whole
and there are no material considerations
is indicate that the decision should be
chosen other than in accordance with the
development plan
and Gil councillor Busby class just what
I was gonna say that's your proposal is
that yeah thank you very much and at
second that's deal yeah yes I would
agree with that I think and Stevens
hit the nail on the head there just one
more point and I think it would also be
useful from some experiences it would
also be useful if members can resolve
that in the event of an appeal in turocy
the authority delegated planning
officers attended probably given but
also being amended all their leaders may
be required yes you are happy with that
counselor Busby to the last bit yeah
that was right absolutely so this was a
this was a point that was put to and
agreed by members when we refused
Branson scheme recently from Gladman
it's just the point really that gives us
the opportunity to taking advantage may
be the places we end up in an inquiry
situation from Council and amending the
council's position to be make it as
strong as possible
if for example we required to reflect
again on on how the needle the ways and
that might be approached if there is an
issue that they feel but photometry
members don't have to face but if you
want to see but I believe that high and
it just means that if we do need legal
authority that might be the better way
baby councillor Busby come to the
bathroom on actually having to take
Steve's advice on though right so we're
sticking with what Steve's just read out
there and I'll asked your second though
which was Kent early hint and are you
happy yeah their blah blah okay but
that's fine right I'll do go to rubber
going to asked for him to do a roll call
of the potent again thank you sure so
again this is for DC 18020 1-0 and I
will now ask you to respond for
against her upstate so counselor suit
airs cancel Melanie Barrett against
house the Peter beer against Casa David
Busby house the John Hinton for Paul
castle Mary McClaren house Adrienne
Osbourne against a griever legal thank
you so it's seven for it's recommended
for refusal sorry it's been resumed
right there we'll go to the second
application which is that exactly the
same they members do you wish to know
into debate on this or do you want to
make a proposal what I'd like to propose
that we refuse that one as well I would
second that mr. chairman for the same
reasons there's no difference between
the application so yes thank you I need
you to tell us that that's all and and
seconded by Councillor in turn right
members we can go into debate you wish
to debate it any more no go straight to
the vote right there's no one in the box
or anything it's been proposed and
seconded
that we the application for the reasons
already indicated do we need to read
them out or can we take that as faith
and I don't think we need to read them
account
unless members if any member
specifically wants us to our absolutely
go through the roll call again thank you
so same same applies if you could please
respond word for against or abstain so
counselor Suez against Casa Melanie
Barrett against house the Peter beer
against house of David does be for John
Hinton for Kylie Jamison somebody
tapping sorry so we've got cancer bleed
Jamison castle Mary McLaren Wow caster
Adrian Osborn against Alison Owen Oh
Castle Eve Parker war and Council Steven
plum for and that motion is carried to
care again 734 legal I was muted than
sorry chairman yes I agree that's 74 yes
I kept that's what I make it as well
[Music]
that I think we've now got to the end of
the meeting members I think we've taken
care of that thing having me Rob yes
yeah yeah well remembers I just like to
say thank you very much for to all of
you and your patients and to all those
public speakers and people who took part
in it we got there we had one or two
little problems but at the end of the
day I think we managed to conduct the
baby District Council Planning Committee
so as a thanks to all of you so thank
you very much and goodbye